this week conflict zone is in Kiev to
meet Deputy Prime Minister Vanek Lumpur
since at say she is in charge of
European integration and euro-atlantic
integration that means pushing for EU
and NATO membership but how realistic
are Ukraine's prospects
[Music]
even a question such a welcome to
conflict zone your Deputy Prime Minister
for European integration but current
membership of the EU is no more than a
pipe dream is it for us Ukrainians it's
a goal it's a dream it's a task it will
take a long time that this dream will
get reality we have actually chosen this
dream and this path during the
revolution of dignity in 2014 and since
then we have been moving on this path we
understand that it's a long road we
understand that it requires a lot of
work internally here from us first and
foremost in order to make sure that we
are compatible with the countries of the
EU in order to make sure that we have
better procedures more transparent more
clear between procedures here inside
them yeah but let's talk about the
perspective of the Europeans I want to
remind you of John Claude Janka the
president of the European Commission he
said I quote Ukraine would definitely
not be able to become a member of vu in
the next 20 to 25 years this is a very
harsh statement isn't it I think
prognosis of specific years in our time
when we are facing so many challenges
and everything is so unpredictable
it is not a most positive thing so I
heard that he had said 10 years 5 years
then you would say I like this prognosis
you know I really think it's difficult
to prague knows anything because three
years ago I think nobody could have
imagined where we would find ourselves
and nobody could have imagined how
difficult it might get with all the
challenges that both the EU and Ukraine
are facing in this moment and we know
that the association agreement that we
are right now fulfilling and is foreseen
for 10 years
we see how ambitious and how difficult
this test is and we hope that we will
manage within this ten years and after
that we'll discuss the let's speak also
about the perspective of your population
opinion polls repeatedly show that your
population is divided on this issue our
population since the revolution of
dignity of 2013 and 2014 has been
totally United and not divided by the
issue of Newtonian notation I'm sorry
but not on this issue Kiev International
Institute of sociology sociology
published a poll showing that less than
half of the population favors
integration with the you well I am going
to cite some other polls that have been
just last week presented here by the
Institute of world policy here politics
here in Ukraine and it was done together
with US aid and with pocket if I'm not
mistaken and that was showing actually
majority of Ukrainians closer to sixty
percent who are favoring the European
integration so sixty percent means it's
a huge minority even it's not a minority
when fifty percent forty percent are
still again no no a sixty percent for
direct joining the EU but then there are
people also who are mostly in favor who
are you know considering this as it as a
path that would be important and we have
to understand this is something that
really unites people it doesn't divide
people and that that is something very
different from what we have had and what
actually quite a lot of external
information propaganda and manipulation
is trying to present about the external
menu prominently our Russian our
neighbors are the external party that is
interested in making sure that Ukraine
is not succeed
in that path that Ukrainian people have
chosen the Ukraine government wants
Ukraine to be a part of the EU but EU
members must also accept Ukraine in
April last year the Netherlands voted
against the association agreement
between the European Union and the UN
Ukraine the EU doesn't want you yet does
it we are not putting the question of
membership and then we spoke about the
association agreement even though the
association agreement which is not the
same than to be a member
absolutely not and even the association
agreement unfortunately for us
Ukrainians it doesn't have the
membership perspective in it and what we
have seen in the Netherlands a year ago
is not that much connected with the
whole issue of Ukraine it is I am
absolutely sure that it is much more
connected to the discussions that are
happening right now in Europe within
European countries with regard to those
Euroskeptics
between the discussion between
Euroskeptics and and those who would
like to preserve the unity of the
European Union and this strength of the
European Union moreover we have seen a
year later after the referendum has
taken place we have seen the disclosure
of the intelligence of the nether
Netherlands that those groups of
so-called Ukrainians in the Netherlands
who were calling against the
ratification of the association
agreement between the EU and Ukraine
have turned out to be Russian citizens
but perhaps the the Netherlands
understood what you yourself said you
yourself admitted just a month ago that
Ukraine is falling behind its own
schedule of implementation what went
wrong as I said it's extremely ambitious
and extremely overarching document the
association agreement and right now we
are it's not only a question of
documents it's a question of
it's a question how the political system
is in reality working in this country
it's not only about political system
it's also about the capacity of the
public administration to deliver it it's
not only a paperwork not but but in
order to actually get everything moving
you really have to to make sure that you
have enough professionals in the in the
public service and that's why for
example one of the horizontal reforms
that we have very much focusing on is
the public administration rate perhaps
there are really other reasons why this
proper problems are here there are
indisputable criteria for EU membership
functioning institutions you just
mention it it's not now as it has to be
the rule of law for example but
corruption makes all that impossible
there is a lot of corruption still in
Ukraine isn't it well I understand why
you are saying this and why
but you have to see that over the last
three years Ukraine has definitely done
much more that it has ever achieved over
the 23 years of its does it mean from
which point of view from your
perspective and we can tell well for
example with regard to corruption that
you've alluded to or the rule of law
when I came in into the airport there
was a big paper which were telling us
everybody was coming in no corruption in
the Ukraine to be honest in Germany in
France you don't need such an advice we
are going through a very difficult and
very intensive period of breaking off
with our colonial past with inefficiency
of this of the state system with
corruption with with vested interests
with with all of those corruption prone
practices that have been here root
not only during the 23 years of first
years of Independence was also during
the Soviet times during the Soviet
empire being present here and what we've
done over this couple of years from the
mayor idea of having anti-corruption
institutions we have passed the
legislation to have them we have built
anti-corruption Bureau we have built an
arrest and prosecution we have built
agency for production let's speak so
let's speak what happens today after all
this was done in transparency
international Corruption Perceptions
Index 2016 I mean last year Ukraine
ranked 130 first out of 176 aren't you
ashamed of that this is this is the
result of all this work as a citizen I
would like to have us moving much faster
but I know how difficult it is and again
100 I want I won't own it to to speak
out again that 130 first of 176 after
all these efforts I'm sure that we will
see the results of Ukraine going up as
we are going up on other indexes as well
in the nearest years because finally in
2016
these anti-corruption institutions
finally have become functional and it
was at the end of the 2016 that we first
had to had 136,000 of Ukrainian public
officials going through a extensive
electronic declaration process according
to a survey published law late last year
by the scent of insights in Survey
Research 20% of respondents had friends
or relatives who had had to pay bribes
in the past six months and nearly 10%
had personally to pay bribes corruption
is an everyday reality in the Ukraine
still I wish you would also cite those
facts that
just the last week six six MPs of the
Ukrainian Parliament have been asked to
be revoked of their immunity against
criminal prosecution by the prosecutor
general because there have been
investigations against them and that are
proving that they have did something
wrong which is unimaginable in the whole
history of Ukraine so you're not
mentioning that fact that about 330
investigations against highest officials
are going on right now in in the
National anti-corruption Bureau and 65
have already been oh six to eight have
been already filed for in diction the
European enlargement Commissioner who is
responsible also for these issues
Johannes Yan said declarations should
target corruption and public
administration not hamper work of civil
society that does not like seeing
progress especially on the road to have
a tighter relationship with the EU he
was speaking about neighbor and about a
legislation that after that decision
demanded that not only the legislation
is on people who are working in the
government but also include civil
activists including anti-corruption
campaigners you're making life difficult
for people who want to make corruption
difficult I'm very glad that right now
there is a working group between the
anti-corruption civil activists and many
working groups do you need in order to
see how there will be between them also
and peace and also representatives of
the presidential administration who are
working on the formula how to ensure
that this stipulation that was passed by
the Ukrainian Parliament with regard to
civil society anti-corruption activists
would be true how did this come I mean
everybody knows they
such a decision wants to threaten these
ones who are working to find out where
is the corruption in the government in
the Parliament Oba in the bureaucracy
why this happened there is a consensus
in the society that this is not a right
path and fullfil for such a decision and
unfortunately some of our MPs have used
the possibility when there was a urgent
need to pass the changes to this
anti-corruption legislation with regard
to our military with regard to our
soldiers that are fighting the war
against Russian Federation and they use
this necessity in urgency to view this
intelligence and that's why that for for
intelligence you mean telogen to decide
like that as I said I'm very happy that
there is this working group and I know
that this about the decision but let's
talk about other questions which are
very important for the European Union
and also for the word there is also the
issue of arbitrary and secret detentions
Human Rights December the crane security
service released the last of 18
prisoners who were known to have been
forcibly disappeared such behavior is a
clear breach of democratic standards and
human rights I am not sure what what you
are referring to really because I think
that Ukraine has been really upholding
the issue of human rights very highly on
its agenda and this is something that
that is of importance for every single
Ukrainian citizen because that's exactly
what was what where they might down came
about yes that's really so so let's
listen to human Watch and Amnesty
International they say that most of
these 18 and other detainees suffer
torture or were at least denied medical
treatment that means Ukraine is no
better or worse than Russia for example
I mean this is existing this is not an
invention human rights Amnesty
International international
organizations searching on these
realities well then it's very good that
they are searching on this realities and
Ukraine has never been hiding any of of
the problems that we might have but
comparing Ukraine to Russian Federation
would be totally totally wrong because
we do know that for example right now
more than 140 of our citizens are being
kept on the illegally kept on occupied
territories of the east of Ukraine often
bus and they are not being left by
Russian Federation - and by those
puppets on the ground by those hybrid
forces on the ground to be visited by
for example International Red Cross
organization there while Ukrainian on
the Ukrainian controlled territory
government controlled territory more
than 30 visits have been happening over
this this period of time to those people
who have violated the Ukrainian law
during this conflict so let's let's talk
now about another issue which is very
important for the Ukrainian early-june
Parliament adopted a law that made
joining NATO a central goal of Ukraine's
foreign policy let me remind you a year
ago the president of the European
Commission dr. Luka said also Ukraine
would definitely not be able to become a
member of NATO in the next twenty to
twenty-five years that's quite
frustrating isn't it well not be you not
the NATO I'm very glad to see that our
parliament has finally responded to the
desire of people and have legislatively
confirmed that our strategic goal is
specifically joining NATO that does not
mean that we are today sending the
membership application to NATO
that it means that we are right now
working on on implementing NATO
standards and NATO credit criteria here
in Ukraine first and foremost in the in
the Armed Forces first and foremost
doing the reform of the Armed Forces and
let me remind you a three years ago we
had almost non-existent armed forces and
now we are proudly defending our stand
one of the steps is also in February
President poroshenko announced that he
would call a referendum on a renewed bid
to join NATO it's now July what it
happened what is going on when will this
happen I don't think that there was a
announcement that someone will
immediately call on referendum so what I
mean there is a decision we're going to
be a member there is a statement I want
to call for a referendum this is very
nice and we are now in the summer 2017
when all these declarations will become
policy we'll get into a reality they are
already a reality they are part of our
policy they are part of the policy that
the government is implementing every
single day it see there are all your
announcements it looks like what has
been it would have been absolutely
irresponsible to only have announcements
because we every single day we are
making changes in accordance to this
their NATO criteria and centers and and
moreover we have adopted the the
governmental plan of information of
raising awareness and for the Ukrainian
people what NATO is besides the
political and military alliance because
after the aggression of the of the
Russian Federation against Ukraine what
we've seen we've seen immediate rise of
the of those people of those who are
supporting the NATO membership of
Ukraine and we've never had this high
numbers over this 23 years of fiery Oh
this is a practical work of every single
day okay so let's talk about let's speak
about the practical work Ukraine's
biggest problem is obviously still the
war with Russia
more than two years after it was signed
the Minsk agreement is showing little or
no effect is it
well Minsk has done something very
important it has stopped this tremendous
bloodshed but unfortunately it has not
led so far too real ceasefire it has not
led so far to the to the old as well as
it was agreed to the withdrawal of heavy
weapons from the touchline it has not
led to the has not so where is the
success the respect exacting Carnegie
Europe says means is this time distant
to fail because it is designed to fail
it never had a chance did it nothing
changed really we do not see Russia
being willing to implement Minsk while
Ukraine is really doing everything
possible and impossible to to to make
sure that we are implementing our part
of the realistic agreements really and
yes and we have we have agreed with our
partners within Normandy format with
Germany and with France that and it was
also signed up by Russian Federation
that there is a need to work out a
specific roadmap where the sequence of
the steps will be foreseen and worthy
the responsibility of the implementation
of the something because you said the
Ukraine is doing everything possible and
Ukraine's prosecutor general you really
chanko doesn't want to implement all the
points either even if it were
theoretically possible to check on
Germany's newspaper Bild said on the
first April 17 quote there can
no general amnesty do you agree he said
we are stressing that it is a part of
the coin it is part of the Minsk
agreement and it is part of the
political political agenda of the Minsk
agreements and it's not political it's
an agreement and the pro circuit general
is saying no it is a political part of
the agreement and before we get to the
political part of the agreement I hope
you would agree that it's important to
have and sustainable and durable
ceasefire only from the beginning of
2017 we have 120 of our soldiers who
have died we have almost 900 of our
soldiers who have been wounded we have
47 civilians who died from the attacks
absolutely accepted but there is an
agreement and this agreement was signed
because all of the victims and on the
1st of April the general said we agree
no he didn't mean that he would he was
probably I'm sure referring to the fact
that first and foremost we have to
ensure that there are security
preconditions to go further and the
heavy weapons that have been had to be
removed withdrawn from the touchline
we are seeing more than four and a half
thousand of violations of the of the why
didn't have anything to do with it has
to do with everything because if we do
not see Russia fulfilling the necessary
security preconditions then it is
extremely difficult to discuss anything
that would be connected with it with the
political will the police asked me
another let me ask you another question
sanctions were invented to to force
Russia to change the policy last week
the you extended sanctions against
Russia but until now the sanction
haven't achieved anything do you believe
in sanctions against Russia sanctions
have unified a unified stance of the EU
and Western world in sanctions and
coordinated approach this challenge only
paid nothing is it is creating the
necessity for Russia to actually return
back to respect the international law if
first wasn't nervous about this sanction
if Russia wasn't feeling uncomfortable
it wouldn't have been trying all this
time to try to to divide the countries
of the EU over the issue of sanctions
thank you varying a country thank you
really it was a pleasure it's my
pleasure thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]